[Applaudissements]
pas besoin de tout ça pas besoin de tout
ça comment ça va
j'aime beaucoup ce pull c'est très tu le
veux
lui donner ça lui fera une robe de
chambre
je suis obligé de mettre un t-shirt
parce que je peux pas le mettre à poil
ça c'est très beau c'est très beau
j'adore je vais être le passé ah bah
c'est très gentil merci beaucoup les a
pas fait des petites talonnettes parce
que vous faites la même taille t'as pas
mis un petit truc
il est beau tu es beau comme ça le noir
allez vas-y oui ben écoutez alors on a
pas non plus il est très gentil avec moi
Cyril il le sera peut-être dans un
instant un peu moins et surtout il y a
un chroniqueur qui a été très très
méchant avec moi c'était à quelle heure
oui alors
nous sommes le mardi 24 février 18h54
[Musique]
lorsque Christelle
entre dans le salon
les lacets des fêtes
[Rires]
on peut faire ça
avec vous moi
ce que tu veux
qu'est-ce qui se passe
mais non c'est la semaine prochaine
t'inquiète pas
qu'est-ce que tu fais allez je
t'embrasse
dans l'émission qui était passé c'est la
semaine prochaine
est-ce que vous voulez commencer avec
une petite caméra un petit apéritif
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour commencer c'est un truc
alors l'American staff peut-être
dans un instant comment ça se passe
[Rires]
Guillaume Guillaume qui s'est fait un
nouvel ami cette semaine problème il
parle pas du tout le même langage
pour laquelle
[Applaudissements]
il y a quelques jours sur ce plateau
vous avez eu un fou rire ah oui on va
parler
mais qu'est-ce qu'elle peut être aussi
drôle pourquoi vous étiez tous morts de
rire les téléspectateurs ont envie de
savoir la drogue est-elle vraiment
omniprésente chez les policiers et les
stars on a vu une sortie là montagne
[Applaudissements]
moi j'adore j'adore j'adore ce mec et
j'adore il est incroyable
question à vous qui nous regardez que
veut dire le mot non je suis Cyril
Hanouna c'est une négation c'est le
contraire de oui réponse a ou réponse B
ça veut dire non je m'en bats les
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça démarre ça démarre une affaire
mais est-ce que vous êtes toujours avec
les années d'expérience aussi concentré
à l'antenne que pendant les magnéto
toujours toujours pas sûr regardez
c'est ouf
mais c'est un chat ça frère
si ça c'est une lionne
si ça c'est un javelot
alors je disais dans c'est possible que
ce soit une gueule
si vous voulez venir un animateur un
conseil ayez le sens de la transition
comme Cyril Hanouna mais c'est plus qui
n'a pas pris plus
tout de suite à l'égard de la
représentation et on va te bouffer allez
j'ai une petite question pour Mathieu
Delormeau est-ce que maintenant à partir
d'aujourd'hui je dois vous appeler
Mathieu Delormeau ou Matthieu de Cohen
je ne sais pas mais je rêve j'ai
l'impression Cyril qu'en ce moment
Mathieu Delormeau se pose beaucoup de
questions sur sa religion oui regardez
tu manges du jambon oui mais en plus du
fromage du fromage tu mélanges le
fromage bonjour je suis pas juste pardon
quand même pour moi tu es juste c'est
gentil c'est parti de la famille
gentil mais en fait Mathieu regardez
bien match de l'Ormeau c'est les mecs
qui se convertit le plus vite au monde
[Musique]
le meilleur le meilleur c'est ah bah
c'est gentil
les personnes juives adorent sortir avec
des Juifs pas du et n'importe quoi je te
dis moi mon expérience et moi j'ai tombé
amoureux d'un garçon et m'a toujours dit
moi je sortirai qu'avec un Juifs
c'est dégueulasse d'ailleurs pour vous
je me convertir
et puis tout se passera très bien avec
vous Cyril il y a deux idoles qu'on peut
pas toucher mais c'est Raphaël Nadal et
Claude Barzotti ça vous fait au moins un
point commun avec Mathieu Delormeau
tu n'y as jamais rien compris je tenais
des chansons de Brel c'est un homme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
quelqu'un vous a sauvagement agressé
lors d'une page de réclame on a les
images du ou de la coupable oui vous
avez été agressé sur ce plateau et vous
me payez pour
dénoncer
les apparences
[Musique]
elle est venue complètement ouf
total tu la voyais faire ça avant est-ce
que tu la voyais
l'attaque de la bouteille dans le but
bientôt dans les salles en Dolce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense vraiment delphine vespiser est
devenue complètement ouf
dans le cul c'est moi mais non
je me dis mais elle est venue vous êtes
deux
amis
j'ai perdu mon sang-froid je ne sais pas
ce qui s'est passé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous imaginez dans un autre bois j'ai
perdu mon sens
j'ai perdu mon
à quel moment vous êtes là et un moment
tu as la bouteille il y a que moi tu te
dis je vais la mettre dans le sud
concrètement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc je vous explique donc je buvais un
coup avec avec Guillaume ici présents
[Rires]
en tout cas c'est votre meilleur rôle
[Musique]
tu fais comme ça
j'ai fini de boire et là je me retourne
et là donc je vois qu'est-ce que je vois
comme ça je vois un cul tendu et donc là
du coup
[Rires]
donc du coup je savais qu'un tour dans
ma tête et j'ai un rêve non mais parce
que ça existe les réflexes qui part donc
comme ça c'est voilà et donc je
m'approche et là on réflexe du coup je
fais comme ça mais je c'est c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
les gens n'ont pas vu la scène
et du coup ça va pas
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
je sais pas je trouve qu'elle est
devenue complètement obsolète
bien sûr
ça ne m'a pas du tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je ne refais pas alors vaut mieux pas
arrêter oui on va garder nos distances
vous êtes vous êtes bien non c'est les
bouteilles j'avoue la vérité
je te l'ai dit tout à l'heure d'abord tu
es très bon pour moi c'est une de tes
meilleurs amis et c'est producteur qui
parle
c'est magnifique c'est très beau c'est
vrai il est très beau
mais je
[Rires]
merci c'est bon alors c'est pourquoi je
mets des lunettes parce que je suis
éblouie par votre charisme en fait
quand tu des conneries si Cyril arrive à
être aussi beau en ce moment c'est parce
qu'il fait quelque chose que très peu
font autour de la table il propose
[Applaudissements]
c'est nouveau c'est nouveau ce petit
détail physique qui a peut-être échappé
les spectateurs mais qui a beaucoup
inspiré Mathieu Delormeau
mais c'est pas fini regardez bien
comment Mathieu Delormeau est très
médisant avec l'indique de l'arnaque
votre serviteur on dira quand même sur
la chronique du nain vendredi
on est d'accord c'est pas un an comment
il s'appelle
le meilleur le meilleur c'est c'est
l'avoir défendu Cyril est-ce que vous
avez vous caution
j'avais oublié ton prénom
exactement
[Rires]
on lui avait fait un cadeau en diffusant
pas l'image qu'il ne voulait pas par
dessus
[Musique]
vraiment de la merde allez bouteille
d'eau maintenant
[Rires]
et bouteille d'eau
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je suis obligé de montrer cette image ça
dépend je demande au public
[Applaudissements]
c'est la dernière fois de ta vie que tu
fais de l'antenne
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas te bramuser
allez en deux coups de téléphone tu es à
la réception
j'ai toujours appris de vous vous êtes
toujours dit faut écouter le public
c'est le public qui parle non
c'est compliqué
je l'aime bien quand même
je devrais mettre si tu dérape c'est
vraiment un ami tout ça c'est en fait
c'est juste méchant là c'est méchant non
c'est pas
moi je suis méchant avec les gens dans
leur dos jamais en face
on est d'accord que Mathieu doit assumer
ce qu'il dit pendant les pub
[Musique]
je vous laisse aller tu peux pas merci
Cyril merci
je prends la défense de l'animateur dont
tu parles merci
j'informe mon patron mon supérieur
hiérarchique du contenu de l'image et je
vous dis ça dans un instant
on a plus le choix de publier
un truc horrible
il dit que truc et c'est tout mais il
vient il vient dire que j'étais quand
même le non l'autre qui fait ça
chronique connard dont on parle c'est
qui la personne d'abord et d'abord du
tout
[Rires]
c'est super merci Sacha
la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
Cyril si vous embête à tout moment je
rentre et j'envoie l'image